so generally other than the uh how would
you say misinterpreting purposefully
misinterpreting the question and giving
a silly answer are there some other easy
ways that people can add humor into
conversations
yeah um okay so how do we add humor into
conversations what i see
i'm coming back to a lot of the the same
things which is your initial
conversational tracks are going to be
totally similar and they already are
totally similar people say the same
things if you're in college they want to
know what major you have if they're if
you're in the workforce they want to
know what you do for a living so having
both an answer that is true and reveals
your values and a playful answer to a
lot of these different things and you
can answer what are the three questions
that you could ask the most uh i
literally went out and split tested
these different things and would just
just answer different stuff
at different times in the night club or
something like that so that is one that
you can do because those are just going
to be free gimmes it's kind of like
uncle jokes the thing the uncle's just
prepared for you to say something
and you have you have a ready-made
response uh in terms of more spontaneous
conversational stuff there's a lot of
different types of humor one of the
russell brand is very fast clever call
back witty that's tougher to implement
an easy one is to say the opposite and
it sounds dumb but if it's a super hot
day and everyone's bitching about how
hot it is and you go out you're like
man it's cold out here i swear to god
you will get a chuckle from people
because what what humor is in many cases
is just when the unexpected occurs it
causes a chuckle so it's not the
funniest way to be funny you know you
can be witty and clever and have
interesting callbacks but
saying the opposite is a very easy way
to just to get laughs and chuckles and
insert humor if you're not the other
thing that i recommend people do because
i do think that it's
our brains
i guess this is more system one just
automatic is you can prime yourself
so what one of rather than thinking of
humor i think how i did it it wasn't by
purposely working in
uh saying the opposite necessarily it
was by watching a lot of chris pratt
before i would go out i just like
watched 10 minutes and i'd watched some
step brothers best of clips and put
myself in that mode of
ridiculous
non-sequitur statement and i would just
talk about prestige worldwide and screw
you know investors possibly you
and point of people and just lift these
lines straight out of movies into
context that it didn't make any sense
and that actually worked really well
because it was i was enjoying it i was
referencing movies that i had fun with
and i was
not taking all of the words that chris
pratt would said but his general
demeanor was was coming through so yeah
trying to make like your fifth best
friend the comedian that you most enjoy
and the vibe that you want to have and
just watching them for 10-15 minutes
before going into a social interaction
was was actually the way that i did it
that's a really cool way to use like
recency bias to
influence because it's
we can't all be tim dillon
you know
that ability to be
who i think actually now tim is
as far as i can see one of the quickest
guys
that's doing sort of conversations on
this circuit like tim's the gay russell
brand at the moment if you hear him on
rogan his ability his ability to be
unbelievably rapid do you see the
most recent rogan where he said
do you think that there's other epstein
islands and he's like yeah better ones
hilton's building them now there's just
slides where the kids go immediately
down and they're straight into a furnace
and you're like holy [ __ ] that was off
the cuff that's disgusting so there is
if you're serious about humor and again
you don't with this charisma stuff uh
storytelling humor you don't need to be
excellent you truly the bar is so low
you could say the opposite and you'll be
the funniest person in a group of most
people but if you really want to go deep
in humor improv comedy classes are
awesome i used to take these uh these
classes
at the pit in new york and there was one
on the west side in los angeles they
train you to we talked about world
building for flirting like how to
structure a thing create a scene all
that kind of stuff but
the specificity that tim dillon is
driving into is not and the tags that he
adds to that right it's not just oh yeah
there's better islands he's got the
slide into the furnace those are those
are uh there's principles of comedy that
guide that and it takes a long time to
be able to do it that quickly but you
can develop that skill through practice
and they will teach you almost
everything you need to know about that
in an improv comedy class if it's if
it's any good so that's another thing
like if you really want to be funnier
improv comedy is is where i would start
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace